thème du feu pour elisabeth bornes
devant le parlement d'abord devant les
députés puis ensuite devant les
sénateurs steve c'est un discours dans
une forme un peu particulière oui les
abbesses bande se présentera donc en
chair et en os face aux députés du
palais bourbon et ça sera bruno le maire
qui se présentera face aux sénateurs au
même moment à 15h le numéro deux du
gouvernement lira le discours écrit par
elizabeth bornes un même texte donc à
l'assemblée nationale et au sénat
simultanément ça peut paraître un peu
bizarre comme ça mais c'est la règle en
2017 l'allocution d'edouard philippe
avait été élu au sénat par gérard
collomb ministre de l'intérieur en 2020
le discours de jean castex avait été lue
par jean yves le drian ministre des
affaires étrangères ont résumé les
numéros 1 vont à l'assemblée nationale
les numéros deux vont au sénat jusqu'en
espagne et yanis juste quand il s'agit
de politique générale
oui le gouvernement ne peut pas
dissoudre le sénat en contrepartie et
bien les sénateurs ne peuvent pas
démettre le gouvernement il ya une sorte
d' équilibre des puissances ou d'équidés
impuissance sous la vème république en
revanche le gouvernement dépend lui
directement de l'assemblée nationale
pour sa survie politique par exemple
lorsque le premier ministre demande la
confiance des parlementaires il la
demande formellement aux députés et non
aux sénateurs qui de toute façon et bien
ne peuvent pas le renverser sait quels
articles de la constitution benjamin
bailly c'est que la confiance c'est la
17 49 bien sûr c'est le carnaval
c'est l'article 49 à noter que quand
même qu'aujourd'hui c'est double ration
d'élise avait deux bornes pour les
sénateurs puisque son discours sera
conclue à 15h par bruno le maire est un
peu plus tard à 21h elisabeth band
viendra heures cesse dans l'hémicycle
pour prononcer bien en chair et en os
son discours de politique générale
légalement rien ne l'obligé à le faire
mais il ya aussi un contexte politique
un contexte parlementaire un peu
particulier en gros elisabeth bande dit
aux sénateurs me voici me voilà je fais
un premier pas vers vous je vais avoir
besoin de vous pour faire passer des
réformes
mots peut-être la tuant sur le fait
effectivement il y aura deux discours
pour elle les avait deux bornes d'abord
elle tient l'assemblée ce qui est normal
et ensuite elle vient au sénat cela
c'était un message important adressé au
sénateurs politiquement parlant il va
elle pouvait pas ne pas le faire
aujourd'hui bien sûr oui je pense que là
c'est important qu elle assoit son
autorité on parle beaucoup de la forme
la savoir si elle avait de ses ailes
aurait dû engager sa responsabilité tout
ça ouais on va s'aimer sur le fait
qu'elle vienne de vote devant le sénat
oui c'est important c'est très important
moi je pense que c'est très important
mais il faudra qu'on parle du contenu
aussi on va en parler et premiers avec
une tête une tonalité un peu différente
aussi devant les sénateurs une bête plus
tourné vers les étoiles qui est
généralement on utilise beaucoup plus le
mot territoire canton en effet le
discours politique générale ici va
compter combien de fois inhalées j'ai vu
en était il trop
c'est un détestable un bourreau des
nôtres at il
prononcé alors c'est vrai c'est vrai
qu'en dehors du périphérique parisien et
j'en viens on utilise assez peu le mot
territoire et que général mais bon
donnant mais c'est important si vous
voulez tout bêtement parce que
l air va être majoritaire dans les
commissions mixtes paritaires ça va être
majoritaire c'est le groupe qui va avoir
le plus de parlementaires députés et
sénateurs compris est donc d'autant plus
content et donc il faut s'adresser au
sénat tout bêtement parce qu'il faut
s'adresser justement à l air ensuite il
faut s'adresser au sénat tout bêtement
parce que eh bien vous pouvez pas forcer
la procédure législative en période de
gouvernement minoritaire comme vous le
faites en période en période longue date
c'est à dire que pour le coup vous allez
avoir menacé de la nécessité de plus
considérer les amendements du sénat
parce qu'il n'est pas dit que si jamais
ces amendements et bien ne plaisent pas
ensuite au gouvernement ils puissent
revenir dessus à l'assemblée nationale
donc les négociations avec le sénat ou
être tout aussi importante qu'avec
l'assemblée nationale et par ailleurs et
bien vous pouvez avoir des liens entre
les deux assemblées prenez par exemple
la ppl mckinsey rien n'empêche si elle
est votée ici que demain un groupe
minoritaire à l'assemblée nationale de
l'inscrire dans sa niche et si jamais
vous trouvez numéro quatre cabinets de
conseil
et donc si jamais un groupe ska est
probable que même la reprend dans sa
niche aujourd'hui vous avez prônant une
majorité pour la voter cette ppl à
l'assemblée nationale donc en fait les
possibilités du gouvernement de faire
barrage aux initiatives sénatoriales ce
soit en termes d'amendements ou de ppl
sont largement émoussé aujourd'hui d'où
la nécessité est bien de prendre langue
avec le sénat comme on prend langue avec
les oppositions l'assemblée nationale
très justement à parler de vote de
confiance dans mon cas mon train qu'elle
compte sur les parlementaires mais elle
ne se soumettra pas un vote de confiance
est arrivé souvent ça c'est arrivé c'est
arrivé quatre premiers ministres avant
elles ne se sont pas soumis à un vote de
confiance maurice couve de murville
michel rocard edith cresson pierre
bérégovoy mais parmi ces 4 2 seulement
sans réellement passé entre les gouttes
puisque michel rocard et pierre
bérégovoy avait quand même engager leur
responsabilité devant les députés sur
des éléments très spécifique de leur
programme la politique au moyen-orient
pour rocard les négociations sur un
traité international le gâte pour
bérégovoy le gouvernement coupe de
murville et le gouvernement cresson sont
donc les seuls sous la vème république à
ne pas s'être soumis à la confiance des
députés l'un avait duré 11 mois et 11
jours l'autre 10 mois et 18 jours je
voulais se tirer les enseignements vous
voulez oui bah elle peut le faire un
puisqu'en effet euros carré bérégovoy en
midi temps avant de le faire sur des
éléments très particulier et dans le
lard de l'alinéa 1er de l'article 49
vous avez simplement inscrit que vous
avez besoin d'une délibération en
conseil des ministres avant d'avoir
cette mise en jeu de la confiance devant
le parlement donc on pourrait très bien
imaginer que dans un mois dans un an
lorsque le gouvernement de madame borne
sera mieux installés et peut-être
lorsque la majorité ce sera pour une
raison x ou y élargi à ce moment là elle
n'ose franchir le pas aujourd'hui il
n'est probablement pas tant pour elle
mais ça ne veut pas dire qu'à terme et
bien ce gouvernement échappera à la
règle
steve leur à plérin les gouvernements
qui n'ont pas fait coup de main levée
les crises ont duré peu de temps ou
alternance et c'est mauvais signe pour
elisabeth la fille c'est très
particulier que vous demeuriez maurice
couve de murville
parce qu'il avait une majorité écrasante
meurice comme le riz les élections en
1968 avait été très favorable au général
de gaulle juste après mai 68 c'est assez
étonnant alors que les élections de 67
avait été assez était passé de très près
il était passé de très près
la majorité la majorité s'est passée
très près pourquoi maurice mon prix de
leurs ils ne demandent pas c'est très
intéressant pour vous tresseur de droit
constitutionnel
c'est parce que l'autorité du premier
ministre et il estime qu'elle provient
et qu'elle procède du président de la
république et qu'il n'a pas à se
soumettre au vote de l'assemblée
nationale vous rendez compte comme les
temps ont changé 1 alors que pour edith
cresson ça n'a rien à voir et du cresson
c'est parce qu'elle n'avait pas de
majorité et que
elle était un peu dans la même situation
que madame borne aujourd'hui donc c'est
très différent il faut pas les associer
c2c de ses deux précédents historiques
voilà deux périodes
on a trois périodes preuve je dirais
précédente très très intéressante par
rapport à notre époque c'est d'abord
celle 58 62 ou là vous n'avez pas de
majorité absolue vous avez une majorité
de bric et de broc derrière le général
de gaulle et qui finalement va se solder
par une motion de censure ensuite vous
avez cette période couve de murville
mais comme l'a très bien dit van réalité
là il s'agit de montrer après 68 que le
vrai pouvoir il est à l'elysée et que
l'éventuelle dyarchie qui avait pu être
esquissée sous pompidou de gaulle et
cetera c'était fini et qu'on revenait
qu'on remettait les choses en ordre avec
un gaullisme j'irai traditionnel très
fort et ensuite vous avez cette période
88 93 où les trois gouvernements qu'on a
évoqué rocard bérégovoy cresson sont des
gouvernements minoritaires et qui à
partir de là et bien sont sur des sièges
éjectables
les discours du général de gaulle vous
parliez de dyarchie il estime qu y a pas
à dire si justement mais c'est hors de
question il n'ya pas à dire si on met
pas sur un pied d'égalité pour les
ministres présidents de la république il
ya le président de la république les
projets unis ce qui est un exécutant
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui est-ce qu'elle
avait d'autres choix elisabeth bornes
valérie rabault qu'était dans votre
évolution d'ailleurs arrivé
ces démissions qui était dans l'émission
dans questions publiques vous l'avais
interviewé elle dit elle dit c'est une
erreur parce que du coup alors à lundi
minuit politique avec un argument qui
fait sursauter pas mal de personnes
notamment notamment des femmes
justement parce qu'elle dit parce que
c'est une femme doit demander un sommet
doit soumettre sa sollicité je veux dire
la confiance de l'assemblée nationale et
je connais beaucoup de concerts par
exemple qu'ils étaient
vraiment étonné par cet art du monde a
fait ça en dehors de ça non moi j'étais
de ceux qui pensaient qu'il fallait
qu'elle sollicite cette confiance parce
que
après tout il n'avait pas trop de
risques a qu à encourir et on me dit le
contraire on me dit que finalement et
d'après ce qu'on dit contrairement à ce
qui était écrit le rassemblement
national n'aurait pas voté la confiance
la confiance ils auraient voté contre il
ne se serait pas tenue et
et que l'heure était très très très très
fragilisée par cet épisode donc voilà
oui je pense qu'elle aurait peut-être dû
quand même mais enfin bon
je suis assez d'accord je pas sûr que ce
soit extrêmement porteur pour elle de le
faire tout bêtement parce que ainsi elle
devait l'emporter en effet sais pas dit
elle le pourrait l'emporter probablement
qu avec l'abstention du rassemblement
national ce qui est une façon de dire
bah en réalité je dépends de
l'abstention et des bonnes grâces du
rassemblement national ce qui n'est pas
forcément une situation très très
confortable 2 ça va pas solidifier sa
majorité symboliquement ça peut être une
victoire mais au bout du compte les
problématiques resteront les mêmes et
certes on pourra plus lui reprocher de
ne pas être passé sous les fourches
caudines d'un vote de confiance mais au
bout du compte l'équation parlementaire
serait restée la même et ensuite et bien
fondamentalement cette situation où fait
qu' il y aura quand même un vote ce que
la nuit déposent une motion de censure
et il est beaucoup plus difficile d'être
renversée via une motion de censure que
d'être renversé vers un vote de
confiance
c'est pas du tout les mêmes mécanismes
c'est pas les mêmes mécanismes c'est le
souk al c'est pas la même majorité
kirghize et par ailleurs et bien jenson
comprennent la motion de censure il ya
uniquement les votes pour exactement
c'est à dire d'une majorité absolue vous
avez besoin de 2 289 députés qui votent
contre vous les abstentions de compte
pour vous d'une certaine façon et on va
pas de même pour le 49 alinéa 1 pour le
vote de confiance et ensuite ma une
motion de censure c'est beaucoup plus
difficile pour l'opposition de
s'accorder notion n'a déjà un
rassemblement national qui a dit qu'il
ne voterait pas avec la nuque c'était
très très prévisible vous avez la nuque
qui va déposer ces motions de censure le
rassemblement national dit nous
mélangerons panneaux aux excès des
blanches nist si demain le rassemblement
national déposent une motion de censure
la nuque dira à 90 ne mélangeons pas
nous avec celle des lepénistes est donc
arrivé à voir 289 votre cours sur un
même texte c'est pas évident il est plus
difficile et plus facile d'avoir de 189
votre pour mai sur différentes motions
avec chaque fois un gouvernement qui
malgré tout tient et puisque vous parlez
des meilleurs solistes on va écouter
justement jean luc mélenchon a rayé
peiné chuté mais il a un avis très
tranché sur cette motion de censure les
le sens de la censure c'est
évidemment de marquer ce qui ne veut pas
la censure sont pris d'un coup de force
contre la démocratie
voter la censure s'est jetée que les
français en majorité n'ont pas voulu que
ce gouvernement et le death que nous
avons déposés et d'avoir sur la motion
de censure sans être d'accord avec le
fond idéologique de la dépêche ni avec
son programme c'est une question de
démocratie
est ce que vous pensez de side
il est rarement gentil avec jean lapeyre
leur chance jjp à l'assemblée nationale
je pense qu'il a dû ps va au devant de
problèmes un peu importants pas un peu
mais important d'abord il va y avoir le
problème de monsieur coquerel quand même
qui va se poser
et
qu'elle va terminer qui va avoir du mal
à maintenir va avoir beaucoup de mal à
se maintenir il n'y a pas deux poids
deux mesures c'est l'arroseur arrosé
et puis je pense que au sein de la nuque
b il ya des sensibilités qui sont très
différentes et c'est vrai que là ils
vont plus voter semble-t-il comme un
seul homme les quatre partis pour cette
motion de censure je suis pas dire que
je suis pas sûr que ça dure
éternellement comme ça
contre cette motion de censure par
exemple sur ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon il parle de coup de force
contre la démocratie il dit on peut
voter la motion de censure sans
forcément d'accord
c'est le principe d'une motion de
censure vous mettez
entre guillemets un texte d'une motion
sur la table et ensuite il faut arriver
à réunir une majorité si votre motion de
censure provient d'un camp politique est
trop clivant ou un contenu trop clivant
vous n'obtenez pas ou de 189 députés
dont il n'y a pas réellement difficile
de la beauté sans être d'accord
idéologiquement avec la nuque
contrairement à ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon bas en effet c'est à dire que
dès lors que
vous avez un contenu de cette motion et
qu'elle provient d'un camp politique qui
apparaît trop clivant et bien il est
difficile pour les députés aient l'air
ou est reine de la beauté il est en
irait de même on attendrait de voir
l'attitude de jean luc mélenchon si
demain une motion de censure venant du r
n était proposée est ce que vraiment la
nuit est ce que vraiment le groupe la
france insoumise voterez pour cette
motion s'est pas tout à fait évident si
une motion de censure devait aboutir
sous ce quinquennat et probablement deux
conditions il faudrait qu'elles viennent
plutôt d'une formation entre guillemets
plus centriste par exemple si le ps et
les écolos se liguer pour déposer en
leur nom une motion de censure si on
avait une motion de censure venant de l
air à ce moment là ça pourrait
potentiellement dans un certain contexte
amenés à les oppositions à se retrouver
il faudrait un contexte singulier alors
on en a déjà eu sous précédent
quinquennat il n'est pas évident qu'une
telle motion de censure déposée par
exemple par lr moment de la sphère
benalla ou au moment de la crise des
gilet jaune est bien ne fasse pas florès
et là on pourrait potentiellement avoir
en effet un renversement du gouvernement
à ce stade là au vu de la décomposition
des oppositions leur éclatement leur
ventilation et au vu du contexte actuel
il est en effet très peu probable qu'une
motion censure d'où qu'elle vienne soit
adopté
est ce que quelque part le fait qu'ils
aient pas de vote de confiance ça
arrange politiquement les rs qui se
seraient pas retrouvés un petit peu
piégé s'il y avait eu un vote de
confiance demandé par elisabeth board
oui c'est probable qu'ils se seraient
trouvés piégés parce qu'ils auraient
probablement choisi l'abstention quoique
bon ça ça demande de réflexion mais je
pense que cet épisode va être vite
va vite se dissiper si vous voulez on se
focalise là-dessus moi ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de savoir qu'est ce
qui va se passer sur le fond quand il va
y avoir des ddd sujet
je suis persuadé qu'on va vers une
chambre de l'abstention que ça va être
une nouvelle page de droit
constitutionnel qui n'a sexe qui va
s'écrire et qu'on va s'apercevoir d'une
chose c'est que finalement le génie
français est telle que les pratiques de
la quatrième république ce pour se
fondre dans les institutions de la vème
république ce que jamais le président de
gaulle où michel debré aurait imaginé je
pense que c'est ça qui va se passer bon
alors combien de temps ça va durer je ne
sais pas mais je pense que ça peut être
jouable il imaginait quand même bien
parce qu'ils font pas il faut se
souvenir qu'avant 58 enfin avant 62 en
réalité il n'y a pas de majorité absolue
à l'assemblée un petit beaucoup le mode
de scrutin a tout changé la troisième
république fonctionne au scrutin
majoritaire à deux tours donc on avait
le même mode de scrutin mais on avait
des assemblées très éclaté et notre
constitution et un bras armé de
l'exécutif justement pour gérer ce type
de situation c'est pour ça qu'en effet
sur le fond c'est très très gérable
parce que notre constitution nos
institutions ont été pensés vraiment
pour de tels chambre des chambres
extrêmement éclaté après je suis
d'accord avec qui il quand il dit que ça
va être une probablement une chambre de
l'abstention beaucoup de textes vont
passer avec l'abstention ça va également
être une chambre de la mobilisation
parce qu'avant ou tandis que la majorité
était majoritaire que tout le monde le
reconnaissait et cetera grosso modo ce
vraiment quand vous vouliez faire un
coup politique met des députés derrière
les rideaux etc puis arrive au dernier
moment pour embêter un gouvernement sur
un amendement sur un texte en règle
générale le fait majoritaire était acté
là si jamais on est une majorité qui
décide de traîner les pieds de ne pas
toujours être présente en séance et bien
c'est un coup politique également parce
que les oppositions étant majoritaires
elles peuvent sur des amendements sur
des articles voire sur des textes
l'emporter conjoncturellement par la
simple mobilisation de leurs forces
encore une fois l'important c'est pas
d'avoir 2 189 députés sur le papier
c'est d'avoir toujours la majorité en
séance à l'instant t j'ajouterai à ce
que dit la jamin c'est que les grands
efforts du général de gaulle 1958 1959
ont été lancés et adoptée à la majorité
relative
[Musique]